Traduttore: Katia Pagani
Revisore: Federico Pepe
Ho un'importante rivelazione da farvi:
io sono Iron Man!
Ahimè non sono Iron Man...
ma sono qui per parlarvi
di un superpotere che abbiamo tutti noi
ben nascosto agli occhi ma che
ci caratterizza più della nostra faccia:
la voce.
È un fenomeno sonoro-acustico
che viene sprigionato dalle corde vocali
ma che interessa molti organi
del nostro corpo
che hanno funzioni ben diverse:
i polmoni, i muscoli, le cartilagini,
le ossa.
Tutti questi organi,
assieme alle caratteristiche particolari
acustiche del nostro corpo,
si sono specializzati in modo estremo per
produrre la voce.
Voglio raccontarvi la storia della voce.
Inizialmente era come quella
degli animali: libera ed emotiva.
Seducente e sperimentale.
Straordinariamente capace di 'imitare'.
Come in un bambino.
Così vasta era la capacità
di produrre suoni della voce,
lo è ancora naturalmente,
che ha permesso
di determinare il linguaggio.
Ovvero una tecnologia straordinaria con
cui l'uomo, e la voce,
hanno iniziato a trasmettere
informazioni, conoscenze, esperienze e
di fatto hanno trasmesso "culture" e tutto
ciò che ne consegue nel mondo.
Inizialmente la diffusione della cultura è
stata orale,
poi è arrivata la scrittura.
Ma questa storia d'amore tra linguaggio e
voce ha in un certo senso privilegiato
il linguaggio e “ingabbiato” la voce.
Il linguaggio, figlio della voce, appunto
è una tecnologia straordinaria, ma, per
riuscire in questa impresa, l'uomo ha
selezionato dei suoni particolari.
I suoni utili alle lingue, “giusti” per
le lingue.
Ma ha tralasciato una cosa
fondamentale della voce,
ovvero la capacità di
trasmettere emozione.
Voglio farvi un esempio:
avete presente il bambino?
Lui piange. Uee uee: ho fame, ho sonno, ho
sete... ed è sempre chiarissimo.
Perchè la voce ha questa immediatezza
emotiva mentre il linguaggio
è, in un certo senso,
mediato dalla parola.
L'uomo ha sempre amato cantare, perchè
la voce è anche canto.
Per quanto il canto stesso sia stato
condizionato dalle regole del linguaggio,
l'uomo non è mai riuscito, o non ha mai
voluto, liberarsi dell'incanto
che la voce suscitava, ad esempio,
provate a pensare
alle acustiche dei monasteri, che
suscitava la voce per lo spettatore
che gli permetteva di raggiungere
il divino più delle parole utilizzate.
Ehm...
Faceva vibrare proprio.
Per favorire questa cosa, sapete, sono
stati rinvenuti all'interno delle mura
dei monasteri dei 'trucchetti' proprio
specifici per perfezionare l'acustica.
Hanno installato delle anfore che
selezionavano alcuni tipi di frequenze:
proprio quelle utili
alla diffusione della voce.
Il canto ha avuto un'evoluzione
straordinaria nella sua tecnica, nei secoli,
però anche in questo caso c'è stato
un condizionamento di tipo estetico.
Ovvero se noi pensiamo al canto per
eccellenza, che è il canto lirico,
è anche chiamato il “bel canto”,
pro prio perchè sono stati selezionati
i suoni "più belli"
a danno di quelli "brutti".
Però così veri.
Dobbiamo aspettare il '900 per essere
scossi come il rock, come vuole il rock,
nelle regole e nelle convenzioni,
anche in questo senso.
Abbiamo avuto delle figure straordinarie.
Ad esempio c'è stato il dadaista,
Kurt Schwitters, che ha scritto queste
“Ursonaten in urlaten”
che sono, è un poema vocalico:
e si è di fatto liberato del linguaggio.
Sono arrivati poi i futuristi e loro hanno
introdotto l'utilizzo delle onomatopee,
esistevano anche prima, ma loro
ne hanno fatto un uso massiccio,
quindi parole che esprimevano nel proprio
senso il suono che facevano, quindi:
drrrrin drriinn cling clang sbamm.
Poi è arrivato Antonin Artaud, ha fatto un
sacco di rivoluzioni Artaud, nel teatro,
ma nell'uso della voce le sue performance
vocali erano inaudite, estremamente emotive.
Sono tanti gli esempi da fare.
Voglio sicuramente ricordare John Cage che
nella sua operazione di liberare la musica
e l'utilizzo dei suoni dai pregiudizi,
di fatto ha aperto la strada
in molte direzioni, compresa la voce.
Ed è stato Demetrio Stratos che ha fatto
tesoro di questa lezione e ha riscoperto
molte delle capacità vocali, anche
studiando dalla sua grande maestra ovvero
la sua figlia neonata, Anastasia,
perchè dalle lallazioni e dalle
sperimentazioni che un bambino fa,
imitando gli adulti per imparare a farsi
capire, nasce la sua capacità di
esprimersi.
Perchè la voce è imitazione,
la voce è mimesis.
Allora nel mondo ci sono delle tecniche
straordinarie che permettono alla voce
di fare cose incredibili.
Certo di suscitare emozioni,
di raggiungere il sacro, di imitare
i suoni dell'ambiente, degli animali.
Ad esempio, magari vi sarà capitato
di sentir parlare del canto armonico,
è una tecnica con cui si possono fare
due suoni contemporaneamente:
Oppure avrete sentito parlare del canto
dei monaci tibetani, il canto khomei,
che utilizzano per la meditazione:
sì, lo so che è un po' strano, però questo
'mostro' ce l'avete anche voi dentro.
Ah, recentemente... non so, se qualcuno
è appassionato di 'Game of Thrones'...
la voce dei 'non-morti', ok?
Poi c'è lo yodel...
Ah, una cosa invece di questi anni, molto
recente, è la beatbox.
Avete presente?
Insomma la voce fa tante cose, è anche una
medicina, ed è un modo che ha il nostro
corpo per produrre energia.
Può imitare anche gli strumenti musicali.
Volevo proprio invitarvi all'ascolto di questo
esperimento e per farlo userò una loop-station
e degli effetti, degli effetti che mi permettono
appunto di, usando gli stessi effetti che
vengono usati in quegli strumenti, del rock
ad esempio, di fare una canzone rock.
E dovreste conoscerla.
Inizio con la batteria.
Grazie.
La voce è un patrimonio di tutti noi.
La usiamo per comunicare, per comunicarci,
e tutti possiamo cantare.
Ci sono, beh certo ci sarà chi è più
dotato e chi meno,
ma ci sono un paio di accorgimenti
da seguire per liberare una voce intonata.
Perchè, magari non ci crederete, ma essere
intonati è naturale.
Ma come nasce la voce?
Molto di quello che sto per dirvi lo
dobbiamo allo straordinario lavoro
di Alfred Tomatis.
La voce non si vede, è nascosta.
Si sente, ma cosa dobbiamo
sentire della nostra voce?
Ci sono due regole fondamentali che
liberano il canto e permettono
soprattutto, così come altre cose
della nostra fisicità, permettono
al corpo di fare il suo lavoro automatico.
Perchè spesso è la testa che lo 'blocca'.
Queste due regole sono
l'attenzione e la postura.
L'attenzione è quella che
dobbiamo dare all'ascolto.
Avviene attraverso le nostre orecchie,
ma anche attraverso
tutta la sensibilità del nostro corpo,
la pelle...
Pensate: l'orecchio è un organo
supertecnologico.
Si forma per primo e già dopo poche
settimane della vita di un feto
è perfettamente operativo.
È in grado di fornirci una cosa molto
importante: la prima esperienza sensibile
di un essere vivente,
che avviene proprio nella pancia.
Perchè così il bambino ha la possibilità
di ambientarsi con i suoni, di riconoscere
i suoni dell'ambiente, ma soprattutto di
riconoscere i suoni della voce della madre.
Perchè poi quel bambino nascerà, e sono
soprattutto....
Beh, provate a pensare che trauma sarebbe
venire al mondo senza questa preparazione
e trovarsi all'improvviso, appunto, in un
mondo di suoni.
E sono le frequenze più acute quelle che
arrivano al bambino, al feto,
perchè i suoni vengono filtrati
dal liquido amniotico.
Queste particolari frequenze stimolano lo
sviluppo dell'encefalo come
una vera e propria
corrente di energia neuronale.
L'orecchio è, di fatto, una dinamo.
Produce energia.
Per garantire questa straordinaria ed
elevata funzione il corpo umano
ha associato la funzione dell'ascolto,
che avviene attraverso la coclea,
è il nostro sensore che ascolta e
trasforma il suono in impulsi nervosi,
assieme a quella dell'equilibrio.
Il nostro sensore, accelerometro e gps,
tutto integrato, si chiama vestibolo
e attraverso i suoi canali semicircolari ha
uno scopo fondamentale: la statura eretta
del corpo umano e monitora
tutti i movimenti nello spazio.
Quindi la coclea e il vestibolo sono fusi
insieme nell'orecchio interno.
Questo perchè per garantire la funzione di
ricarica energetica corticale, che è
necessaria per lo sviluppo del nostro
cervello, l'orecchio ha bisogno
di una posizione molto specifica
per sentire bene tutte le frequenze,
soprattutto quelle acute.
Allora noi dobbiamo parlare della postura.
La postura corretta, qual'è?
Lo dicevano i nostri maestri a scuola:
“dritti come un bacchetto!”
No?
Come un'antenna.
Vi farò vedere cosa succede
in questo modo.
Allora: per avere una postura corretta è
sufficiente, diciamo, ruotare un pochino
il bacino in avanti, così, e allo stesso
tempo...allo stesso tempo
avere la sensazione di una corda che
ci 'tira' dalla sommità della testa, ok?
Succedono due cose che vi invito ad
osservare:
le mie costole si alzano e si aprono
e si bloccano.
Quindi l'unico muscolo che lavorerà sulla
respirazione sarà quello specifico:
il diaframma,
che è uno dei crucci di chi studia canto,
etc.
Questo muscolo si attiva automaticamente
nel momento in cui noi abbiamo la postura.
Succede un'altra cosa fondamentale: ovvero
la laringe, dove sono contenute le nostre
preziose corde vocali, si appoggia alla
colonna stessa, quindi allo scheletro,
e nel momento in cui noi iniziamo a
suonare le nostre corde vocali
la vibrazione viene trasmessa alle ossa
che, essendo cave, la trasferiscono
in tutto il corpo.
Questa si chiama voce ossea, voce interna.
È molto preziosa per chi usa la voce
a livello professionale, ma per tutti.
Ecco perchè nell'atto cantato si dice che
è tutto il corpo a cantare.
Nell'atto cantato noi liberiamo le nostre
emozioni.
Come diceva Aristotele "determina, il
canto, una catarsi, una purificazione".
Sciogliamo le tensioni fisiche del nostro
corpo, perchè la voce ossea ha delle
vibrazioni che sciolgono proprio le
tensioni che abbiamo e ricarichiamo
il nostro cervello di energia.
Grazie proprio a queste frequenze acute
che stimolano proprio
lo sviluppo dell'encefalo. Bene.
Ci sono poi delle situazioni particolari
che aiutano a cantare,
come dicevamo prima sulle acustiche
dei monasteri, ce n'è un'altra che
probabilmente conoscete:
avete presente il bagno?
Sì...
Il bagno stimola a cantare.
Questo perchè la sua particolarità, ovvero
di essere un ambiente riflettente,
grazie alle piastrelle, determina
una sorta di riverbero naturale
in cui le frequenze sembrano avvolgerci
e cantare diventa più facile.
Per cui vorrei ora invitarvi a fare
un esperimento con me: forza!
Andiamo tutti in bagno.
Mi sa che non ce lo lasciano fare!
Vi chiedo allora cortesemente
di unirvi ad un esperimento collettivo
con me e di cantare tutti insieme
una canzone. Vi chiedo di alzarvi in
piedi così avete la possibilità
anche di mettere in pratica subito questi
due consigli: attenzione e postura.
Per fare questo esperimento abbiamo
pensato di suddividere la platea
in quattro: cardo e decumano, ok?
Allora: praticamente ci sono 6 blocchi.
I primi due blocchi sono insieme, per cui
vedete, ci sono degli amici di TEDx
che stanno definendo dove arriva,
ad esempio, il primo blocco,
il secondo blocco è quello più
in alto sotto alla galleria.
Il terzo blocco.
E il quarto blocco è questo.
Il nostro quinto blocco è la galleria, voi
entrerete in scena dopo, e mi raccomando:
avete un ruolo spettacolare, per cui
abbiate pazienza che prima inizio
a preparare i nostri musicisti.
Ci state?
Yeahh!
Bene.
Allora: volevo assegnare...
Partiamo dal basso.
Facciamo una canzone, facciamo proprio una
canzone.
Partiamo dal basso, e il basso lo assegno
al blocco numero 2, perchè loro sono sotto
la galleria e quindi hanno una situazione
acustica che favorisce le note basse.
Ok?
Dovete fare così, vi prego di imitarmi.
Un po' di coraggio, vi prego.
Se vi riesce difficile come tonalità vi
consiglio di fare l'ottava sopra, e quindi
Bene.
Si può fare di più.
“Si può fare di piùùù”
Ok, vi chiedo di ricordarvi
la vostra parte.
Ora chiederò al nostro primo blocco
di fare la chitarra.
Ok?
Sempre tre note. Voi dite:
è più facile, no?
Beh, no.
Vorrei che la mimaste la chitarra, ok?
Per cui il risultato è così:
No, questo non è il risultato. É così:
Yeaah, bellissimo.
Bellissimo.
Ok?
Yeaaahh
Bravissimi.
Adesso chiederò al nostro blocco numero
tre, anche voi in galleria,
di fare la parte bassa del
nostro pianoforte vocale.
Ok?
Che fa così.
Voceeee!
Liberate la voce!
Grandi, grandi.
Bene.
Ora chiederò al nostro blocco numero 4
di fare la parte più alta
del pianoforte invece
Sempre due note, come
i nostri amici del blocco 3.
E fanno così:
Yeaaahhh!
Facciamoci un bell'applauso, sì.
Ok, allora, galleria, portate
un attimo di pazienza.
Non vi insegno nulla a voi, perché
la sapete già fare la parte.
Ma prima componiamo la
nostra musica, e quindi vorrei,
e qui iniziano le cose difficili,
mettere insieme i vari blocchi.
Vi chiedo solo di prestare attenzione.
Ad un certo punto, quando partiranno dalla
nostra galleria, vi verrà la tentazione di
seguirli.
Aspettate un po', vi faccio un segnale, vi
faccio...ve lo dico, vi faccio un segnale.
tipo... così... no?
Dopodichè vi faccio un altro segnale,
perché siamo già in time-up, ok?
e farò così...e tutti quanti concluderemo
la nostra canzone, ok?
Quindi il primo segnale...
ci uniamo al coro...
E con questo segnale... chiudiamo, ok?
Bene.
Allora chiedo al nostro blocco numero 2 di
iniziare con il basso.
Naturalmente abbiamo la loop che ci aiuta
a memorizzare la parte.
Ok?
Quindi era... tre note di basso...
Va bene anche la variante...
ok.
Io faccio la batteria...
Bene.
Blocco 1 siete pronti con la nostra chitarra?
Mi raccomando la posa... assolutamente rock!
YEAAAAHHH
Bene.
Il blocco numero 3... siete pronti?
Due note.
Voce!!
il blocco numero 4.
Wow!!
Questo è rock'n'roll!
OK.
Quando faccio così ci uniamo al coro.
Quando faccio così chiudo.
Ora libererò la nostra galleria.
Siete pronti?
Dovete fare una cosa molto speciale...
che fa così...
Bravissimi.
Quindi: liberate la vostra voce!
It's time to rock!
Meraviglioso il popolo di TEDx.
TEDxVerona è fantastico.
Grazie.